حريق في طائره بسبب شاحن متنقل هل اصبحت
قنابل موقوته وتفاعلكم ينفرد بوثائق رسميه
من التحقيق مع فارس كرم واول تعليق من
ميريام فارس ولباحث عن يوزر على تويتر جهز
نفسك لدخول مزاد اهلا بكم
[موسيقى]
اظهر مقطع فيديو متداول في تايوان لحظات
صعبه مره فيها مسافرين علامه طائره كانت
متجهه من تايوان الى سنغافوره
ازيك
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
الدخان اللي شوفتوه داخل مكسوره الطائره
سببه حريق والحريق سبب الشاحن متنقل او
باور بانك كان مع احد المسافرين وارتفعت
حرارته وانفجر في اللحظات الاولى
للاستعداد الطائره للاقلاع وتسبب في جروح
طفيفه لحامل الباور بانك وصديقه اللي جالس
جنبه وبعد الانفجار اللي صار تم التعامل
مع الموقف من قبل طبعا طواقيم الطيران
اللي موجودين وتم افراغ الطائره من الركاب
وفحصها بشكل دقيق وبعدين عادت واكملت
رحلتها الى سنغافوره هذه الحادثه بتخلينا
نفكر يعني كثير في التحذيرات اللي بتطلقها
شركات الطيران عن المواد المحظوره في
المقصوره واللي من بينها الباور بانك اللي
في حالات الانفجار وبتشكل خطر على كثير من
مستخدمينه ففي شركه طيران بتمنع منعبات
اصطحاب الباور بانك واجهزه الشحن المتنقله
في مكسوره التيار لكن في شركات بتسمح
بوضعها مع الراكب في مقصوره الطيران
الداخلي ولكن مثلا بتشترط شروط معينه مثل
انه يكون سعر معين عموما ومؤخرا ومع كثره
الاجهزه اللي بنستخدمها صارت كل الناس
تقريبا يعني بتشيل شواحن وتنقله وتضارب
قوانين شركات الطيران بخصوصها مربك صراحه
ومخيف خلينا نحكي في الموضوع اكثر ونفهم
اكثر من كابتن محمود القطيار وخبير سلامه
جويه اهلا فيك معنا يا كابتن اذا تقدر
تشرح لنا في الحاله مثلا اللي صارت الان
هذه على الطياره ايش ممكن يكون صار
مساء الخير على حضرتك وعلى كل الساده
المشاهدين هو طبعا حادث عارض وجديد من
نوعه وهنحتاج دراسات كثير لكن واضح جدا ان
هناك كهربائي حصل بين الشاحن المتنقل
وواضح جدا يعني من الدراسه المبدئيه
والشكل المبدئي ان هو تم واصله
بالشاحن الموجود على سياره نفسه وحصل بس
كهربائي بالاثنين بيبقى ادى الى انفجار
الشارع همم لان كل المؤشرات يعني لا تؤدي
الى ان يحدث اي انفجار للشاحن في الظروف
الطبيعيه يعني على سبيل المثال لو هو
بيستخدمه الراكب وهو بيشحن التليفون
والمحمود نفسه هو ما زال على الارض والضغط
الجوي لم يرتفع
بالصعود لا يوجد اي شيء يستدعي ان هو يحدث
هذا الشيء الوحيد المحتمل يكون حدث وهو
اقرب الظن ان هو بدا يشحن الشاحن المتنقل
نفسه في ال- همم
الجهاز المعدل الموجود على الطياره او
وسيله موجوده
في كل الطائرات الحديثه دلوقتي سواء مكان
عن طريق اليو اس بي او عن طريق
اللي هي الشاحن العادي طريقه الشحن
العاديه
وواضح ان المس الكهربائي حدث من هنا وهو
ده اللي خلى حصل الحريق او حصل الدخان
مرعب طيب افتراضا لو هذا الكلام كان صار
وهم في الجو
الضيافه الجويه همم انا شفت الفيديو
مع الامر همم الركاب حتى لما كان في حاله
ظهروا ان هم يبعدوهم علشان يسمحوا نفسهم
ياخذوا المساحه الكافيه للتعامل مع الامر
هو اللي عملوه في هذه اللحظه هو هو اللي
كان هيحصل في الجو بالضبط بالمناسبه
الطياره يعني همم لم تتاثر بالشكل اللي
يخليها همم يبقى فيها حاجه انزعاج او لا
تصلح لها لكن هو طبعا بما ان الطياره كانت
في الاصل على الارض فالطيار يعني اثر
السلام ولف همم وعاود اضربه ثاني لكن
بالمناسبه يعني الامر ده لو كان حصل
بالطياره طائره ممكن جدا ما كانش يغير
مساره كان ممكن جدا يكمل الى وجهه الوصول
ده بيكون بعد الحريق الضيافه الجويه هي
اللي التقرير عن الارض
يعني في مطارات او طيران بتروحوا يقول لك
لا لازم تخلي الباور مع العفش في طيران
يقول لك لا لازم تشيلوا في شنطه ايدك معك
على الطياره يعني هذا في تضارب طب مثلا لو
كان في العفش ايش صار هذا الحريق في العفش
ولا الماس
اه المشاهدين ان اي دخان او حريق بيحصل في
مخزن العفش يوجد بكل مخازن العفش طفايات
حريق بيقدر الطيار ان هو اولا الطيار عنده
اجهزه انذار بتقول له النشيد دخان او في
حريق في مخزن العفش وهو في طفايات حريق هو
بيقدر فريق همم يعني همم
خبره القياده في بعض الازرار وبعض
التحكمات في هذه تطفيات الحريق بيقدر ان
هو ي- يستخدمها لاطفاء الحريق وبالمناسبه
هم بتبقى اكثر من واحده على حسب نوع واا
الطياره وهمم هو كمان بيظهر له اذا كان
الحريق تم اطفائه بالكامل اما زال مستمر
اذا تم اضافه بالكامل فبيعمل اجراءات او
حتى اذا زال مستمر هو بيقرا بينزل في اقرب
مكان وبيقدر يتعامل معه والطيارين بتتدرب
على ده باجراء دوري كل ست شهور بس كيف نجد
نفهم التضارب في موضوع انه من شركه لشركه
ومن مطار لمطار بانجال كلام مختلف انه
ساعه حطوه معكم في شنطه يدكم وطلعوه
المقصوره وساعه لا خلوه مع العفش او
الحقائب في تحت الطياره يعني
الامر الجدل عليه حسب من 2010 مع
البطاريات الليثيوم لما حصل برده همم
انفجار او حريق لاحد البطاريات وبعديها
بقى البطاريات الجسم والشواحن المتنقله او
الكبيره همم في الحالتين هو المؤامره اصبح
متروك لتقييم سلطات المطار وشركات الطيران
يعني سلطات المطار بيبقى لها حدود معينه
وشركات الطيران قادره ان هي يكون لها هي
كمان معين الامر برده اصبح غير مرتبط
بالسلام الجويه فقط ولكن اصبح له بعد
تجاري او يعني اقتصادي لان يعني في
البدايه لما كان الامر في ضعف التيار
والشركات والمطارات اخذت قراره عدم صعود
البطاريات الليثيوم كم عدم صعود الشواحن
اثر اقتصاديا لان في ناس بقت مش عايزه
تسافر عليها وبتسافر على حاجات ثانيه في
شركات ههه
نعم الناس انهارت ايه لانه يعني اللابتوب
الاشياء التيليفون كل شيء
في شركات ومطارات عملت ما هو اكثر عملته
على حسب قدره يعني قيمه الامر بقدره
الشاحن او قدره البطاريه يعني اذا كانت
هتقدر يطلعها اكثر من 100 وجه تعامل معين
في يعني تعددت بصراحه الطرق ولم يكن هناك
امر ثابت بس اعتقد ان بعد هذا الحريق
المسؤولين عن السلامه الجويه في منظمات
الطيران العالميه هيعملوا تحليل مخاطر
واعتقد ان في توصيات مهمه هتطلع في الامر
واعتقد ان التوصيه الاولى والاهم انه لن
يتم من السماح بشكل هذا الشاحن على
الطائره اليهود افتراضيه اللي انا قلتها
صحيحه وهي اقرب
معانا في الطياره لاي درجه لازم نقلق من
حدود هذا الشيء او احتماليه او فرضته
انا انا عندي اعتقاد مبادئي ان هذا كمان
ان النوع او الجوده بتاعت الشاحن هي اللي
ما كانتش كويسه لان هي دي برده تكون عامل
مؤثر فهل نوع هيكون عليه دور هو طبعا بما
انه حجم
المرضاب كلها
الطياره
الجويه بالتحليل المخاطر وبالتوصيات اللي
بتطلعها وهي يعني السبب الرئيسي هو اللي
هيبين لنا شكل التوصيات هتطلع ان شاء الله
كابتن محمود القطيار وخميس شكرا لك
طيب وعلى فكره الحادثه اللي شفتوها مو
الاولى الانفجار باور بانك علامه رحله
طيران ففي سنوات سابقه شهدنا حوادث مماثله
في شهر اكتوبر العام الماضي كان في متداول
مقطع فيديو الانفجار باور بانك في مطار
كازاخستان
طيب يعني احنا كمستخدمين الان ايش نعمل
كيف نضمن انه الباور بانك اللي معانا كويس
وما يسبب مصيبه قشر انه ما ينفجر او يعمل
حريق صديق مع المحرر التقني عبد الله
السبع اعطانا الشرح الكافي
البطاريات الاضافيه شيء نعتمد عليها بشكل
كبير في حياتنا الفتره الحاليه ليه لان
وقت السفر خاصه تكون طالع وتتمشى وغيرها
وتفضل بطاريتك وانت تصور وغير فتحتاج
البطاريه عشان تشحن جوالك عشان تكمل تصوير
وتنشر في ملصقات اجتماعيه المختلفه لكن
ايش المشكله المشكله انك لو انت استخدمت
بطاريه تجاريه انه ممكن تنفجر باي لحظه
ومشاكل البطاريات التجاريه ايضا انها ممكن
تتلف جوالك وتسبب لك مشاكل في جوالك فلذلك
اول شيء لازم تحرص عليه استخدام البطاريه
اصليه الشيء الثاني البطاريات الاصليه لها
عمر افتراضي وايضا لازم تستخدمها بطريقه
همم يعني ما تكون همم شديد في استخدام هذه
لانه ترميها مثلا او شيء ممكن تسبب مشاكل
همم وبعدها ممكن تنكسروا ايضا بعدها ممكن
تسبب بحرائق اذا سمح الله زي ما شفنا قبل
همم فتره بسيطه في بيوت طالعات ان عندهم
صار عندهم مشاكل الحرائق او المقطع اللي
كان الشخص داخل الطياره او صار عندهم
حرائق فلذلك صحينا البطاريات مفيده لكنها
هي نقدر نقول عنها ممكن تتحول الى
قنابلوقوته لو ما استخدمتها بشكل صحيح
اهلا من جديد من اربعه اشهر تابع العرب
تفاصيل الخلاف اللي صار بين الفنانين مريم
فارس وفارس كرم واللي وصل للاسف للشتاء
والقضاء وفي اكتوبر تم استدعاء فارس كرم
والتحقيق معه وتركه بضمان محل اقامته بعد
ما تعهد بعد عدم التعرض
لكم هنعرض لكم حصريا المستندات الرسميه
اللي بتتضمن تفاصيل الدعوه واقوال فارس
كرم الازمه بدات في الاعلام بكلام عن
اعتراض فارس على صوره بوستر لحفل بيجمع
الفنانين في السعوديه وحجم صوره فارس
مقارنه بصوره مريام ميريام وقتها طلعت
وضحت وقالت انه فارس زينه الشباب وانه هي
ما لها دخل بالبوستر يعني
انا
ما بحب انه ينخلق خلافات مانا موجوده فارس
خيره الشباب وانا بحبه كثير والله يوفقه
يمكن زعل من حجم الصوره بس بالنهايه ولا
انا ولا فارس من قرر في الشركه هي اللي
عملت الحفله وفي في اداره جايه فوق الشركه
يا اللي هي الترفيه بالسعوديه وكلنا بنعرف
هن بقرروا كيف تكون احجم الصور مش
لكن فارس كرم ردوا كان مختلف
شفنا صوره الاعلان بجده انت ميريام فارس
اصغر شويه او فيها حلوه وصغيره الشباب
[موسيقى]
حبيب قلبي
مو حرزانه وعيب اللي صار ووضحت انه هي
اختارته لمشاركه الحفل من بين عده فنانين
فارس ما سكتوا بالعكس تمادى ووصل الموضوع
لقمه ولمن غرد التغريده اللي شايفينها
امامكم الان وفيها كلام غير قابل للعرض
وحتى اضطرينا انه نغطيه
تمام هذا الكلام مريام فارس وعدد باللجوء
للقضاء على شان تجيب حقها وبالفعل هذا
اللي سوته فالدعوه تقدمته في زمن قياسي تم
النظر فيها بالنظر طبعا لانه تحولت
الموضوع كل القصه هذه كلها تحولت لقضيه
راي عام فالانتقادات نزلت على فارس كرم من
كل جيهان مو بس من محبين ميريام لكن كمان
خاصه من اللي اعتبره وكلامه اهانه لكل
النساء مو بس مريام واللجوء للشتم المراه
بشرفها دائما انه هذه الطريقه اللي على
طول نشتمها بشرفها في اي خلاف يصير مع اي
امراه
احنا في تفاعلكم مثل ما قلنا لكم مشاهدينا
معانا اليوم حصريا المستندات الرسميه اللي
بتبين تفاصيل الدعوه اللي رفعتها ميريام
فارس ضد فارس كرم ومعاها تفاصيل استدعاء
والكلام اللي قاله امام القاضي ومثل ما
شايفين امامكم اعترف باللي قالوا وفي اول
القاضي الجزائري مثل ما شايفين امامكم
ادعى بحق فارس كرم وهذا يعني انه قاضي
التحقيق بما انه احاله القضيه للمحكمه
فمعناها انه شاف في اعتداء على مريام هذا
غير طبعا انه القضاء الزم بعدم التعرض لها
واجبر انه يحذف التغريده هذا كله انتصار
لمريام فارس ضد فارس كرم الاستهان من اول
كثير بموضوع لجوءها للقضاء
بصراحه المستندات كان فيها تفصيله ثانيه
لفتتنا جدا فعند سؤال فارس كرم في التحقيق
عن التغريده اعترف ان هو اللي كاتبها لكن
تبريره كان ملفت فقال انه بالشتيمه اللي
كتبها ما كان يقصد اهانه مريام كامراه
وانما كان قصده بس انها ثرثاره ولئيمه
انا سمعت تفسيرات كثير كلام بس الكلمه هذه
اكيد لا تعني قيمه بس يعني بس عشان يعني
بس عشان الواحد يعني كل واضح يعني طيب
نقول كلمه الحق صراحه طيب قدام هذه
الوثائق ما قدرنا ما نتذكر ظهور فارس»
انا بدي اياها تروح على القضاء
لحتى تعرفيه حجمها لقد وين راحت قدامي
ولا
هيجيبوا لك اياهن بده ياخذوني
مثل هذا احنا ارتفع لكم تواصلنا مع مريم
وطلبنا تعليق منها وهي اكتفت بانه تقول
انها وعدت الناس انه تجيب حقها وحق كل
الستات وفد بوعدها وانه حقها رجع لها
عموما نحن ترى من اول يوم دونا فيها هذه
القصه واحنا بنقول وبناكد انه فارس كلم
فارس كرم عفوا له حق الرد تماما وبنرجع
اليوم وبناكد على هذا الكلام وبنقول انه
حق الرد تماما وانه صراحه حتى نحن كثير
حابين نستفسر على جزئيه الثرثاره ولا قيمه
وربطها بالكلمه هذه كثير جزئيه مهمه حابين
نعرفها اكثر منه يعني
يبدو انه مالك تويتر الى الماسك لازاله
المستمر في محاولات ايجاد حل اكبر مشكله
بتواجه تويتر وهي الضعف الايرادات فصحيح
انه تويتر من الصخمه ولكن ارادتها مقارنه
بغيرها من المنصات ضعيفه وماسك من اول ما
استلم تويتر وهو بيصدر قرارات وسياسات
جديده بتساهم نوعا ما في رفع ارادات
الشركه كلها تحت عنوان ادفع وهذه التقارير
وهذه المره تحديدا التقارير بتتكلم عن
طريق مبتكره وجديده على تويتر ففقارير
قالت انه تويتر بتدرس طرح اسماء مستخدمين
للبيع في مزادات اون لاين المقصود هنا
يعني اليوزر نيمز والهندز والاسماء اللي
راح تطلع من الاول هي اسماء الحسابات غير
نشطه من سنوات واصحابها ما بنستخدموها ولا
حتى سجلوا دخول من سنين يعني بدل ما تفضل
كده اسماء المستخدم محجوزه لهم على الفاضي
وكثير منها حتى يوزرات مميزه جدا فخلاص
تويتر يرجع يطلق صراحه وتنبع وكان الى
الماس كمان لما احنا الفتره للموضوع
ونشرته قال فيها ان التويتر راح يحرر
مليار ونص حساب في سبيل اتاحت اسماء
للمستخدمين الجدد واكد ان الحسابات اللي
راح تحذف لي حسابات غير نشطه فلا بتغرد
ولا سجل الدخول على المنصه اصلا من سنوات
وطبعا في نقطه لازم نذكر فيها وهي انه
شركه تويتر بتمنع اصلا بيع وشراء اسم
المستخدم لكن هذا الشيء كان طبعا بيصير في
السوق السوداء ولكن يبدو انه السياسه
الجديده يتغيرت للشركه والموضوع راح يصير
قانوني ورسمي وانا ماسك ما راح يترك طريقه
يحاول من خلال زياده الشركه وخاصه مع
المشاكل لوجهها من وقت اشترت تويتر واللي
من بينها توقف الاعلانات على المنصه
ومغادره كثيرين من بعض فرد رسوم على
التوثيق طيب
وبمناسبه الحديث عن تويتر وماسك الايرادات
والفلوس والمزادات ففي خبر ثاني عن ماسك
مهم جدا اليوم
اللي معودنا على المفاجات والابتكارات
والفكره المستقبلي والارقام القياسيه
وتصدر القوائم بمختلف انواعها حقق رقم
قياسي جديد وهذه المره كمان دخل في موسوعه
جنس بس للاسف مبرر لكن بالخساره فموسوعه
الارقام القياسيه سجلت ماسك اكثر شخص
بيخسر ثروه شخصيه في التاريخ
ماسك منه نوفمبر 20 21 خسر
182 مليار دولار بينهم مصادر ثانيه بتقول
انه الرقم اكبر من كده وبيصل الى 200
مليار في كل الاحوال يعني فك هو رغم انه
تحديد يعني بالضبط خسر كم صعب لكن كسروا
الرقم
كسر الرقم القياسي وكسره المراحل في الرقم
القياس السابق لاكبر خساره شخصيه كان رجل
اعمال الياباني ما سيشون واللي سنه خسرت
58 مليار دولار اما ماسك فخسر 200 مليار
تقريبا مثل ما قلنا ثروه نزلت من 320
مليار في 20 21 ل 138 مليار في يناير 20
23 الخساره طبعا سببها الاساسي شراء اولى
توتر وكل الجدل اللي صار وكمان انخفاض في
اسهم شركه تسلا وبعد كل هذه الخساره ماسك
لسه من اغنى اغنياء العالم طبعا لكن خسر
المركز الاول ونزل للثاني وترك منصب
الاغنام لبرنارد ارنو صاحب مجموعه قلبي يا
اللي ثروته الحاليه هي 190 مليار دولار او
مع هذه الارقام الحلوه المشاهديننا يلا
الله يوعدنا جميعا بالمليارات هذه كلها
وانا عدت والعوده احمد في امان الله
[موسيقى]